[Musique]
pour éviter les accidents les shadoks
ont décidé de ranger la terre mais les
déménageurs shadoks n'y comprennent rien
ils ne sont pas assez éduqués et du quai
les shadoks oui malheureusement c'était
pas une chose facile
les cerveaux des shadows qu'on ait fait
avec une capacité est tout à fait limité
il ne comportait dans tout que quatre
cases et encore c'était pas toujours
vrai parce que bien souvent il y en
avait deux bouchées pour remplir les
cases déjà c'était pas facile et je la
prenais un certain temps c'est alors que
comme on sait la difficulté parce que
collet case était plein il y avait plus
de place et le château qu on ne pouvait
plus rien lui apprendre
si on essayait quand même alors
obligatoirement il y avait une case qui
se vidait pour faire de la place
un de sorte que quand shadoks avec une
tête plein voulez apprendre quelque
chose il fallait qu'ils en oublient une
autre exemple si un shadok avait appris
à marcher avec une case et que plus tard
il est a pris trois mots avec les trois
autres cases et bien si en plus on
voulait lui apprendre à faire du vélo le
château qui ne savait plus marcher comme
il n'avait que quatre cases
évidemment les shadoks ne connaissais
pas plus que quatre noms c'était gars
but zoo et me
[Musique]
ouais vous comprendrez donc facilement
qu'il n'y avait pas du tout suffisamment
de mots pour toutes les choses qui
existaient et il y avait des quantités
de choses qui avait le même mot or ces
conditions que le grand plan
d'aménagement sadok de la terre risquait
de poser certaines difficultés
[Musique]
et